With our Golden State Warriors and the playoffs, we thought we'd re-broadcast this piece about the design of basketball. So we'll give you nerd something to say when everyone is talking about the playoffs. It's one of my favorite episodes. Hope you enjoy it. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Tomorrow night, 15,000 cheering fans will pack Madison Square Garden in New York City to witness a giant basketball double header. In that cheering crowd, sitting in row C, C-11 will be a modest 77-year-old man. Those fans won't know that he made possible the games they're watching, but you're going to meet him now. That tape is from an old New York radio show called We The People.
鉴于金州勇士队和季后赛的到来，我们决定重播这期关于篮球设计的节目。这样当大家都在谈论季后赛时，你们这些书呆子也能插上话了。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一，希望你们喜欢。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。明晚，15000名欢呼雀跃的球迷将挤满纽约麦迪逊广场花园，见证一场盛大的篮球双赛。在欢呼的人群中，坐在C排11号座位的将是一位谦逊的77岁老人。那些球迷不会知道，正是他让这些比赛成为可能，但你们现在就要见到他了。这段录音来自纽约一档名为《我们人民》的旧广播节目。
The guest is James Naysmith, 125 years ago in 1891. Naysmith was a PE instructor at a small college in Springfield, Massachusetts, when a particularly bad snowstorm struck. For days, the students couldn't go outdoors, so they began rough housing in the halls. We tried everything to keep them quiet. Something had to be done. One day I had an idea. I called the boys to the gym,
嘉宾是詹姆斯·奈史密斯，那是125年前的1891年。奈史密斯当时是马萨诸塞州斯普林菲尔德一所小型学院的体育老师，当时一场特别严重的暴风雪来袭。学生们好几天都不能去户外，于是开始在走廊里打闹。我们试过各种方法让他们安静下来。必须得做点什么。有一天我有了个主意。我把孩子们叫到体育馆，
divided them up into teams of nine and gave them an old soccer ball. I showed them two peach baskets I'd nailed up but each ended the gym. I told them the idea was to throw the ball into the opposing team's speech basket. A lot of sports don't have such a definitive point of origin, but this one does.
把他们分成九人一组，给了他们一个旧足球。我向他们展示了两个我钉在体育馆两端的桃子篮。我告诉他们，这个主意的核心就是把球投进对方的桃子篮里。很多运动都没有如此明确的起源，但篮球有。
I blew a whistle and the first game of basketball began. That day in 1891, James Nasemith invented basketball. And what rules did you have for your new game, Dr. Nase Smith? Well, I didn't have enough. And that's where I made my big mistake. The boys began attacking, taking and punching in the clenches.
我吹响了哨子，第一场篮球赛开始了。1891年的那一天，詹姆斯·奈史密斯发明了篮球。那么，博士，您为您的新游戏制定了什么规则吗？嗯，我制定的不够多。这就是我犯大错的地方。孩子们开始进攻，拉扯、推搡、扭打在一起。
They ended up in a free for all in the middle of the gym floor. In subsequent weeks, Nase Smith would go on to make more rules for the game. Some of those are still around today, like the one that says players can't run while holding the ball. They have to dribble it. But there was one thing, not so much a rule, but a design decision that he made back in
他们最终在体育馆地板中央打成了一团。在随后的几周里，奈史密斯继续为比赛制定了更多规则。其中一些规则沿用至今，比如球员持球时不能跑动，必须运球。但有一件事，与其说是规则，不如说是一个设计决定，他在
1891 that continues to define the way the game has played. He had to decide how high to hang the peach basket. That's Kerry Champion. She's an anchor at ESPN and host of the Be Honest podcast, and she's going to help us tell our story today. Nase Smith chose to hang the peach basket at 10 feet above the court floor. There was a running track that went around the court at that level, but otherwise the decision was pretty random, and just a little higher or a little lower, and everything would be different. That arbitrary decision to put the basket at 10 feet caused the game of basketball to take
1891年做出的决定，至今仍在定义这项运动的比赛方式。他必须决定把桃子篮挂多高。那是凯莉·钱皮恩。她是ESPN的主播，也是《诚实一点》播客的主持人，她今天将协助我们讲述这个故事。奈史密斯选择将桃子篮挂在离球场地面10英尺高的地方。那个高度正好有一条环绕球场的跑道，但除此之外，这个决定相当随意，只要再高一点或低一点，一切都会不同。那个将篮筐设在10英尺高的随意决定，使得篮球运动
shape around the tallest players. But it happened gradually. In fact, in the beginning, the game was played by shorter, less imposing players. In the very early days of the game, people didn't really have a conception of height, having really any importance of the game. That's writer and journalist Andrew Heisel. So a lot of the high scores in the very early days were like six foot tall. It was not until a few decades in that team started recruiting really tall guys. And at the time they were sort of
围绕着最高的球员成型。但这发生得很缓慢。事实上，起初这项运动是由身材较矮、没那么魁梧的球员进行的。在比赛的早期，人们并没有真正意识到身高对比赛的重要性。那是作家兼记者安德鲁·海塞尔。所以早期很多高分球员身高也就六英尺左右。直到几十年后，球队才开始招募真正高大的家伙。而在当时，他们通常被
referred to often as goons. Nowadays if you play a little rough or dirty, you might be called a goon. Back then, Big Men were sometimes called goons just because they were big. The first so-called goon to have a major impact on the game was a big white dude named George Mican who played for the Minneapolis Lakers from 1948 to 1956. He was a 6 foot 10 monster who wore big round spectacles when he played. Two giants jump in front of the lighter basket, notice the comparative size of referee Ackman. Mike entowered over his opponents and broke scoring records with his strength and accuracy. Where's Mike in forces this way through the center spins and shoots and it's all by all of the men.
称为“暴徒”。如今，如果你打球有点粗野或肮脏，你可能会被称为“暴徒”。那时，大个子有时被称为“暴徒”，仅仅因为他们个子大。第一个对比赛产生重大影响的所谓“暴徒”是一个名叫乔治·麦肯的白人大个子，他从1948年到1956年效力于明尼阿波利斯湖人队。他是一个6英尺10英寸的怪物，打球时戴着一副大圆眼镜。两个巨人跳起在篮筐前，注意裁判阿克曼的对比体型。麦肯高出对手一头，凭借力量和准确性打破了得分纪录。麦肯强行挤过中路，转身投篮，球进了。
Watch Mike and get such a force they actually had to change some rules in the game to offset his advantage. For example, the rule against goal tending came about because of Mike. goal tending is the act of catching or batting away another player shot as the ball is on a downward path toward the basket. Mike and was so tall he could just stand under the basket and swat away shots by the other team. Goaltending was banned in 1945.
看麦肯的冲击力，他们甚至不得不改变一些比赛规则来抵消他的优势。例如，禁止干扰球的规则就是因为麦肯而产生的。干扰球是指在球处于向篮筐下落的过程中，接住或拍掉对方球员投出的球。麦肯太高了，他可以站在篮下直接拍掉对方球队的投篮。干扰球在1945年被禁止。
But rule changes didn't stop George Mike and or his fellow big man from dominating defensively and offensively. You started to see people saying it's too easy to score. They were really sort of disgusted. They thought this should be a triumph to get the ball in the hoop, not something that happens a hundred sometimes a game. The ease with which these super tall players could put the ball in the basket was alarming people.
但规则的改变并没有阻止乔治·麦肯或他的大个子同僚在防守和进攻上的统治地位。你开始听到人们说得分太容易了。他们真的感到厌恶。他们认为把球投进篮筐应该是一种成就，而不是一场比赛发生一百次的事情。这些超高球员把球投进篮筐的轻松程度让人们感到担忧。
The traditionalists didn't like the way the game was going, but they had no idea what was about to hit them. Slam dunk! It's a laker. was about to hit them. The Dunk. Sometimes called the slam dunk. The first one in an organized game happened in 1936, but dunking didn't really get going in basketball until the 1960s. And man, the traditionalist, they hate it the dunk.
传统主义者不喜欢比赛的发展方向，但他们不知道接下来会发生什么。扣篮！是湖人队。接下来会发生什么。扣篮。有时被称为灌篮。第一场有组织的比赛中的第一次扣篮发生在1936年，但扣篮直到20世纪60年代才真正流行起来。天哪，传统主义者，他们讨厌扣篮。
But not just because it was a new, unconventional way to put the ball in the basket, the dunk became political. The key year is 1966. That's Matt Andrews. My name is Matt Andrews. I teach American History at UNC Chapel Hill and I have a particular focus on sport and society.
但这不仅仅是因为这是一种将球投进篮筐的新颖、非传统的方式，扣篮变得政治化了。关键年份是1966年。那是马特·安德鲁斯。我叫马特·安德鲁斯。我在北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校教授美国历史，我特别关注体育与社会。
So it was in 1966. In the NCAA Championship game, Texas Western, with an all black starting five, easily defeat Adolf Rupp's all white University of Kentucky team. This win by Texas Western against Kentucky was a big deal in the college basketball world. Kentucky was one of the last major college teams in the country that still didn't have any black players. The coach of Kentucky was a guy named Adolf Rupp, many viewed him as a racist. According to the sports correspondent Frank DeFord, who was in the Kentucky locker room
所以那是1966年。在NCAA锦标赛决赛中，德克萨斯西部大学凭借全黑人首发阵容，轻松击败了阿道夫·鲁普执教的全白人肯塔基大学队。德克萨斯西部大学战胜肯塔基大学在大学篮球界是一件大事。肯塔基大学是全国最后一批没有黑人球员的主要大学球队之一。肯塔基大学的教练是一个叫阿道夫·鲁普的人，许多人认为他是个种族主义者。据当时在肯塔基更衣室的体育记者弗兰克·德福德说，
that night, the language Rupp used against the Texas Western players sent a chill down his spine. And there was this moment right at the beginning of the game, where Texas Western's David Latin gets the ball and makes a move toward the hoop. The defender in front of him is Pat Riley. He go on to win nine NBA titles as a player, coach, and executive, and Latin flies over him. Riley's like six foot four, stockly both,
那天晚上，鲁普对德克萨斯西部大学球员使用的语言让他不寒而栗。比赛刚开始时有这样一个时刻，德克萨斯西部大学的大卫·拉廷拿到球，向篮筐移动。挡在他面前的防守者是帕特·莱利。他后来作为球员、教练和高管赢得了九个NBA总冠军，而拉廷从他头上飞过。莱利身高约6英尺4英寸，体格健壮，
and Latin just rises above him and slams the ball through the hoop. Texas' victory and Latins' dunk were seen as direct challenges to the establishment. After all, this was 1966. There was a lot going on in America. The Black Panthers have become a visible force. In Oakland, the Panthers had armed and organized themselves to protect their communities from brutal racist police. And many white Americans were worried a revolution was about to take place. Black Power was this new evocative phrase.
拉廷直接从他上方跃起，将球扣进篮筐。德克萨斯的胜利和拉廷的扣篮被视为对建制派的直接挑战。毕竟，那是1966年。美国发生了很多事情。黑豹党已经成为一股可见的力量。在奥克兰，黑豹党武装并组织起来，保护他们的社区免受残酷的种族主义警察的侵害。许多白人美国人担心一场革命即将发生。“黑人权力”是一个新的、令人回味的短语。
So that the failure to pass a civil rights bill isn't because of Black Power, isn't because of the student nonviolent 40. What's so interesting about this phrase is it's lack of specificity, no one is exactly sure what black power means. Into this context comes the dunk, and the dunk seems to be black power manifest on the basketball court. The dunk is physical, The dunk is forceful.
所以，未能通过民权法案并不是因为“黑人权力”，也不是因为学生非暴力运动。这个短语最有趣的地方在于它的模糊性，没有人确切知道“黑人权力”意味着什么。在这种背景下，扣篮出现了，扣篮似乎是篮球场上“黑人权力”的体现。扣篮是身体上的，扣篮是有力的。
You know, when you lay the ball in, you're laying the ball in. But when you dunk, you're doing it to someone. And at a time when so many white Americans are uneasy with the specter of black violence, the dunk becomes suspect. Then to scare people like Adolf Rupp even more comes a player called Lu Alcindor. He would later change his name to Karim Abdul Jbar and become one of the most exciting and famous players in the history of the game. But in 1967 he was a young man, seven feet two inches tall, and already tearing up the college game with his vicious dunks and fast movement.
你知道，当你上篮时，你只是把球放进去。但当你扣篮时，你是冲着某人去的。在许多白人美国人对黑人暴力的幽灵感到不安的时候，扣篮变得令人怀疑。然后，为了让像阿道夫·鲁普这样的人更加害怕，一个叫卢·阿尔辛多尔的球员出现了。他后来改名为卡里姆·阿卜杜勒-贾巴尔，成为篮球史上最令人兴奋和著名的球员之一。但在1967年，他还是一个七英尺二英寸高的年轻人，已经凭借他凶猛的扣篮和快速的移动在大学比赛中大杀四方。
How senders surrounded by white shirts. Unstoppable. So the NCAA, that's the National Collegiate Athletic Association, made a decision. The only way to stop this guy was to get rid of the thing he did best, the slam dunk. In 1967, they banned the dunk. And for 10 years, there's no dunking in college basketball. Lou L. Sender, aka Kreme Abdul Jabbar, was not happy about this. In fact, he explicitly said that the only reason for the ban was because they were scared that black guys like him were going to take over the game, although he used much stronger words. Regardless, the slam dunk was done, and College basketball was sent back in time for 10 years.
阿尔辛多尔被白衣球员包围。势不可挡。于是NCAA，即全国大学体育协会，做出了一个决定。阻止这个家伙的唯一方法就是废除他最擅长的东西——扣篮。1967年，他们禁止了扣篮。在接下来的10年里，大学篮球没有扣篮。卢·阿尔辛多尔，也就是卡里姆·阿卜杜勒-贾巴尔，对此很不高兴。事实上，他明确表示，禁令的唯一原因是因为他们害怕像他这样的黑人会接管比赛，尽管他用了更强烈的词汇。无论如何，扣篮被禁止了，大学篮球倒退了10年。
Basketball was in a bad place. The NCAA administrators had made an arguably racist decision to ban the slam dunk. Meanwhile, in the professional league, the NBA, players could still dunk, but fans were losing interest. Here's Andrew Heisel again. This is for the NBA considered like the low point of the league. There are all of these pieces written about how the game is dying and nobody wants to watch it. And there's all these questions about why.
篮球处于一个糟糕的境地。NCAA的管理人员做出了一个可以说带有种族主义色彩的决定，禁止了扣篮。与此同时，在职业联赛NBA，球员仍然可以扣篮，但球迷们正在失去兴趣。安德鲁·海塞尔再次登场。这对NBA来说被认为是联盟的低谷。到处都是关于比赛如何走向死亡、没人想看的文章。关于原因也有各种疑问。
Nase Smith's original accidental design decision to put the basket at 10 feet had inadvertently given us this beautiful and exciting slam dunk, but it had also caused the professional game to revolve too much around these super tall players. The game had gotten jammed up around the net. People weren't passing as much. They just hand the ball to the giant guy and he'd stand under the basket trying to put it in. This had the effect of slowing down the plane, and that slowness was draining the game of its excitement. Basketball needed a design solution.
奈史密斯最初将篮筐设在10英尺高的偶然设计决定，无意中给了我们这种美丽而令人兴奋的扣篮，但也导致职业比赛过于围绕这些超高球员展开。比赛在篮下变得拥挤不堪。人们传球变少了。他们只是把球交给大个子，然后他站在篮下试图把球投进去。这导致比赛节奏变慢，而这种缓慢正在耗尽比赛的兴奋感。篮球需要一个设计解决方案。
People suggested a lot of fixes. No backboard, a convex backboard, a smaller basket, a bigger ball, a smaller ball, a no scoring zone around the basket, and even a height cap. Another group of coaches caught for the hoop to be raised to 12 feet. None of those changes caught on. And then, this guy comes along. Well, we feel that those people who are not under contract solubligation, if they'd like to take a look at us, we would... So, remember George Mican, the original NBA Goon 6-foot tenages tall with big round specs.
人们提出了很多补救措施。取消篮板、凸面篮板、更小的篮筐、更大的球、更小的球、篮下禁投区，甚至身高限制。另一组教练呼吁将篮筐提高到12英尺。这些改变都没有流行起来。然后，这个家伙出现了。嗯，我们觉得那些没有合同义务的人，如果他们想看看我们，我们会……所以，还记得乔治·麦肯吗，最初的NBA“暴徒”，6英尺10英寸高，戴着大圆眼镜。
Well, in 1967, he was working as a travel agent in Minnesota where he used to play. When he gets a call from a couple of guys asking if he wants to head up a new professional basketball league that would compete with the NBA. What it was old NBA friends have to say about his new job. Good luck, baby. I mean, it really was just sort of making it up to go along. It was simply what's getting an idea. And let's see what we can do here. That's Terry Pluto who wrote a book about the founding of this new league.
1967年，他在明尼苏达做旅行社代理，那是他曾经打球的地方。他接到几个人的电话，问他是否想领导一个新的职业篮球联盟，与NBA竞争。他那些NBA老朋友对他的新工作怎么说？祝你好运，宝贝。我的意思是，这真的只是边走边编。这仅仅是一个想法。让我们看看我们能在这里做什么。那是写过关于这个新联盟成立的书的特里·普鲁托。
They called it the ABA, the American Basketball Association, and George Mike and became its first commissioner. They were trying everything to get fans reengaged in the game. Sometimes they featured cow-moaking contests for entertainment, and one half-time show in Indiana involved a wrestling bear called Victor. Most of their ideas didn't stick. A lot of times good ideas are like that. They're one of 12 things that people stuck to the wall and out of the 12.
他们称之为ABA，即美国篮球协会，乔治·麦肯成为了它的第一任总裁。他们尝试了一切方法让球迷重新参与到比赛中来。有时他们会举办挤奶比赛来娱乐，印第安纳的一场中场秀甚至涉及一只叫维克多的摔跤熊。他们的大多数想法都没有坚持下来。很多时候好的想法就是这样。它们是人们贴在墙上的12件事之一，而在那12件事中，
One became really good. One helped a little bit and the other 10 were almost embarrassing. In this case, one of the ideas was really good. In fact, it's the design solution that arguably saved basketball, and the secret star of this story that we're telling right now. The 3-point shot. So all you sports fans know this, but originally shots from the field were all worth two points. But the ABA's innovation, which they actually borrowed from an earlier defunct week, was
一个变得非常好。一个有一点帮助，另外10个几乎令人尴尬。在这种情况下，其中一个想法非常好。事实上，它是可以说拯救了篮球的设计解决方案，也是我们现在讲述的这个故事的秘密明星。三分球。所以所有的体育迷都知道这一点，但最初所有的投篮都只值两分。但ABA的创新，他们实际上是从一个更早倒闭的联盟借来的，就是
to draw an arch line about 22 feet away from the basket, and any shot made from behind that line was now worth three points. The ABA was trying to please the fans. Fans get excited when they see a three-pointer, but they can also go and practice the shot at home. It's more a egalitarian. That's Ramona Shelberd, senior writer for ESPN.com. It's the sense that if I practice hard enough, I don't have to be the most athletic guy
在距离篮筐约22英尺的地方画一条弧线，任何从那条线后投进的球现在都值三分。ABA试图取悦球迷。球迷们看到三分球会很兴奋，但他们也可以在家里练习这种投篮。它更平等。那是ESPN.com的资深撰稿人拉莫娜·谢尔本。这是一种感觉，如果我练习得足够刻苦，我不必成为球场上最有运动天赋的人，
in the court. I don't have to be an incredible dunker. It's something that when fans watch it, they think, oh, I could do that too. In 1976, the NBA merged with the ABA, and three years later, they brought in the three-point shot. At first, it was about pleasing the fans, but they slowly came to realize something about the three-point shot. When you'd study it, if you shoot 35% on three-pointers, and you shoot 45% on two-pointers, if you just break it down, it makes so much more sense to build a team around
我不必成为一个不可思议的扣篮手。当球迷观看时，他们会想，哦，我也可以做到。1976年，NBA与ABA合并，三年后，他们引入了三分球。起初，这是为了取悦球迷，但他们慢慢意识到关于三分球的一些事情。当你研究它时，如果你三分球命中率是35%，而两分球命中率是45%，如果你把它拆解开来看，围绕三分投篮建立一支球队更有意义，
three-point shooting because you're going to score more points and that's the point of the game. And now some teams have decided that the way to win is to concentrate on three-point shots. When the NBA first introduced the three-point shot, games featured only a couple of three-point attempts. This season, it's more than 10 times that. And if there's any team that's demonstrating the value of the three-point shot right now, it's the Golden State Warriors from California and know who Steph Curry is, he's about 6'3", so he's short by NBA standards. But this hasn't stopped him from being the star of the team and of the whole NBA. I think every kid growing up in America now is trying to be Steph Curry.
因为你会得到更多的分数，而这正是比赛的目的。现在一些球队已经决定，获胜的方法是专注于三分球。当NBA首次引入三分球时，比赛中只有几次三分球尝试。这个赛季，次数是那时的10倍多。如果现在有哪支球队正在展示三分球的价值，那就是来自加利福尼亚的金州勇士队。知道斯蒂芬·库里是谁吗？他身高约6英尺3英寸，按NBA标准算矮了。但这并没有阻止他成为球队乃至整个NBA的明星。我想现在美国长大的每个孩子都在努力成为斯蒂芬·库里。
He is skinny and doesn't seem to have anything physically dominant about him, and yet when you watch him play, he's electric. Curry can hit three pointers for Golden State from really anywhere he likes, which makes it hard to defend against him and balances the influence of the big men. Because if there are guys like Curry who can score from anywhere, then the 7-foot guys have to move away from the basket, where they're most useful, to defend. And once you allow players to score an extra point from shooting further out, the game spreads out. You get a whole new game.
他很瘦，看起来没有任何身体上的统治力，然而当你看着他打球时，他充满活力。库里可以从他喜欢的任何地方为金州勇士队投中三分球，这使得防守他变得困难，并平衡了大个子的影响力。因为如果像库里这样的人可以从任何地方得分，那么7英尺高的球员就必须离开他们最擅长的篮下位置去防守。一旦你允许球员通过从更远的地方投篮来多得一分，比赛就散开了。你得到了一场全新的比赛。
The game has changed for the better. There's no doubt about it. That's former Indiana Pacer Jerry Harkness. Harkness was a player in the NBA and the ABA. Because the game is exciting. The game is running shoot, quickness, defense, opening the game up, making it more aggressive. But even though the three-point shot has had a balancing influence, some traditionalists still don't like it. And I think it's basketball. You know, I think it's like a kind of like a circus sort of thing, you know, and why don't we have a five point shot and a seven point shot, you know, where does it stop? You know, that's sort of thing, but that's just me. That's just old school.
比赛变得更好了。毫无疑问。那是前印第安纳步行者队球员杰里·哈克尼斯。哈克尼斯曾是NBA和ABA的球员。因为比赛很刺激。比赛是跑轰、敏捷、防守，打开局面，让比赛更具侵略性。但尽管三分球产生了一种平衡的影响，一些传统主义者仍然不喜欢它。我认为这是篮球。你知道，我觉得这有点像马戏团之类的东西，你知道，为什么我们不设五分球和七分球呢，你知道，这在哪里停止？你知道，就是那种事，但这只是我。这只是老派。
That San Antonio Spurs coach Greg pop of it speaking to ESPN about Steph Curry's Golden State Warriors last year. What pop of it you're saying kind of echoes what people said about the dump 50 years ago. That it's a trick, a departure from the fundamentals of basketball. And I kind of agree with Coach Pop. But even pop of it seems to think that the three point shot is here to stay. So a certain degree you better embrace that you're going to lose and every time we've won a championship three point shot was a big part of it.
那是圣安东尼奥马刺队教练格雷格·波波维奇去年对ESPN谈论斯蒂芬·库里的金州勇士队时说的话。波波维奇所说的某种程度上呼应了50年前人们对扣篮的评价。那是一个把戏，是对篮球基本功的背离。我有点同意波波维奇教练的观点。但即使是波波维奇似乎也认为三分球将长期存在。所以某种程度上你最好接受它，否则你会输，而且我们每次赢得总冠军，三分球都是其中重要的一部分。
Instead of designing the beautiful powerful dunk out of the game, we designed a counterbalance, the three point shot, and now the game is more inclusive than it's ever been. You've got these little guys that can shoot bombs from anywhere on the court, and they're still room for the big guys close in. The three pointer and the dunk have become the Yin and Yang of basketball. All of this has sort of been by accident. The 10-foot tall basket, the dunk, the three-point shot. But then again, the game wasn't carefully designed in the first place.
我们没有把美丽而强大的扣篮设计出比赛，而是设计了一个平衡物，即三分球，现在比赛比以往任何时候都更具包容性。你有这些可以从球场任何地方投出炸弹的小个子，而大个子在近处仍然有空间。三分球和扣篮已经成为篮球的阴阳。所有这一切在某种程度上都是偶然的。10英尺高的篮筐、扣篮、三分球。但话说回来，这项运动起初也不是精心设计的。
Really it came about because all James and Ace Smith wanted was to stop some rowdy kids from getting into too much trouble. And the whole thing started with a couple of peach baskets I put up in a little gym 48 years ago. I guess it just goes to show what you can do if you have. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, The Houston Rockets actually broke the Golden State Warriors record for the most threes in his season this year, but the Warriors, led by Steph Curry, are still dominating the NBA from beyond the 3-point arc. In game 2 of the 2017 NBA Finals, Golden State set a new record for the most three pointers
它之所以出现，是因为詹姆斯·奈史密斯想要的只是阻止一些吵闹的孩子惹麻烦。整个事情始于48年前我在一个小体育馆里挂上的几个桃子篮。我想这正好说明了如果你有……（此处音频重复）休斯顿火箭队今年实际上打破了金州勇士队单赛季三分球命中数纪录，但由斯蒂芬·库里领衔的勇士队仍然在三分线外统治着NBA。在2017年NBA总决赛第二场比赛中，金州勇士队创下了单场总决赛三分球命中数的新纪录。
in a final game. This episode was a collaboration with our friends at ESPN, and as part of a podcast mini-series they produced called Dunki Mentories. It's a collection of stories all related to basketball's slam dunk. It ran last year, but it's still available on the ESPN mobile app iTunes or whatever you get your podcasts. Joe Sykes reported and produced this story for us and for ESPN with help from Ryan Nantel and Memorcon Stern, Delina Termin, Joe Fuentes, and Kevin Wildes. Special thanks to Jody Evergan for hookin' us all up. Also check out Cari Champion's podcast Be Honest, where she has candid
本集是我们与ESPN朋友们的合作，也是他们制作的名为《扣篮回忆录》播客迷你系列的一部分。这是一系列与篮球扣篮有关的故事。它去年播出，但仍然可以在ESPN移动应用程序、iTunes或任何你获取播客的地方找到。乔·赛克斯为我们和ESPN报道并制作了这个故事，瑞安·南特尔、梅莫康·斯特恩、德琳娜·特明、乔·富恩特斯和凯文·怀尔德斯提供了帮助。特别感谢乔迪·埃弗根为我们牵线搭桥。也请查看凯莉·钱皮恩的播客《诚实一点》，她在那里与体育、音乐和娱乐界的一些大人物进行了坦诚的对话。
conversations with some of the biggest names in sports, music, and entertainment. This piece was inspired by a vice article by Andrew Heisel will have a link to it on our website. On the 99% of visible teams, senior producer Katie Mingle did the heavy lifting on this one, with Avery Troll from in Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sharif Yusif, and me Roman Mars. Kurt Colestead is the digital director and Terran Mazza is the office manager. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
这篇文章的灵感来自安德鲁·海塞尔的一篇Vice文章，我们将在我们的网站上提供链接。在《99%隐形》团队中，资深制作人凯蒂·明格尔在这期节目中承担了繁重的工作，艾弗里·特罗尔、德莱尼·霍尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、谢里夫·尤西夫和我罗曼·马尔斯也参与其中。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，特兰·马扎是办公室经理。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街制作。
If you want to learn about another little game design innovation that saved the game of basketball, look for episode number 77 of this program. It's called Game Changer. It's about the shot clock. You'll like it. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Org or on Instagram Tumblr and Reddit too. But the nexus of all things 99PI is that 99PI dot org.
如果你想了解另一个拯救了篮球比赛的小型游戏设计创新，请寻找本节目的第77集。它叫《游戏规则改变者》。它是关于进攻时限的。你会喜欢的。你可以在Facebook上找到《99%隐形》并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg，也可以在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注。但所有99PI事物的中心是99PI.org。
Radio til PI. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX的Radio-til PI。你目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子来发表评论。